Enough killing going on.
We have all the evidence we need
that we need to do more.
Doing nothing is unacceptable.
- That was my guy.
Senator Cory Booker has fought
to keep guns
off the streets of Newark,
and battled Congress to pass
common-sense gun reform.
We'd figure out
how to get rid of guns
over international pancakes.
Let's say this plate is America.
Something on this plate
will kill you.
Bacon/guns.
- Right.
- Americans love bacon/guns,
but too many Americans die
because of bacon/guns.
So how do we stop dumb people
from eating bacon?
- Well, first of all,
you are ridiculously condemning
when you call people dumb,
and you insult
their intelligence.
- All right, Dad.
- I don't wanna take away
their bacon or their guns.
- You're a democrat, right?
- I am a democrat.
- A liberal?
- I am a guy that is--
can be considered liberal
in my views.
- Okay, so am I.
So between you and me...
- Yes, between you and me.
- When are we getting rid
of the Second Amendment?
- Well, we're not gonna get rid
of the Second Amendment.
It's something
that we don't wanna do.
- Because you can't do it?
- No.
In order to make people safe,
we don't need to throw out
one of our
constitutional amendments.
- Yeah, but--
I mean, come on.
How many constitutional
amendments do we have?
- Well, we've thrown out some
in the past,
which I'm really happy we did.
- Yeah, you gotta update
these things,
and this is maybe
the second oldest one.
You think I'm walking around
here with an iPhone 2?
- That's the fear tactics
that often people
want you to believe.
That somebody's gonna try
to get rid of all the guns.
That somebody's coming after
their guns.
That is not a necessary thing.
- More bacon/guns, please.
Booker,
like many other democrats,
felt like his hands were tied.
Last June, in response to
the Pulse nightclub shooting,
senators filibustered
to expand background checks
and prevent gun sales to people
on the terrorist watch list,
while House democrats staged
a sit in,
which resulted in...
shit all.
[indistinct shouting]
Efforts to pass
any meaningful regulations
continue to get shot down
by republicans
and the gun lobbyer.
Insisting these liberal elites
are coming for your guns.
- The tactic has been
not only are we going
to not pass
background check laws
or close the terrorist loophole,
but we're also gonna
take those agencies
that could be helping us,
the CDC, ATF,
and we're gonna cripple them.
- One agency that's
being crippled is